تتبع التمويل غير المشروع
لدولة نووية مارقة يقودنا تحقيق لمدة شهر
إلى قارب صيد في مابوتو ،
موزمبيق يتوخى الحذر ، لذلك هناك
صياد كوري شمالي هنا على متن القارب
لا يريدون منا التحدث إليهم وقد
علقوا  هذا القارب بين اثنين
آخرين مخفي جيدًا
الهدف النهائي لكيم جونغ أون هو تطوير
صاروخ ذي رؤوس نووية قابل للتطبيق
يهدد بضرب مدن في جميع أنحاء
الولايات المتحدة ولكن العقوبات
لاذعة وتتخذ إدارة ترامب
موقفًا أكثر صرامة وهناك
المزيد من الشر.  روابط أكثر من مجرد عدد قليل من
محققي قوارب الصيد الذين
يتتبعون كل صواريخ أرض-جو المحمولة ،
وأنظمة الرادار العسكرية للدفاع
الجوي ، وتجديد الدبابات هو
قائمة طويلة من
بيونغ يانغ التي تصدر خبرتها المميتة
مقابل المال الصعب
حتى إلى المناطق الداخلية النائية في موزمبيق
لتعزيز المنشآت العسكرية مثل
هذا ما تقول الأمم المتحدة إن تدريب قوات النخبة
لمدة عامين على الأقل أخبرتنا المصادر العسكرية
أن الأمر كله يخضع لعقوبات بسبب
أكثر من عقد من الزمان ، فكيف يحافظون
على سرية العملية ، يقودنا المسار
إلى أحد أكثر الطرق ازدحامًا في ماكوتو ، لذلك
وفقًا للوثائق ، هذا هو
المقر الرئيسي للمبعوث التجاري الكوري الشمالي
هنا في مابوتو ، الذي استعرضته سي إن إن
، الوثائق التي تحمل اسم شركة واجهة غامضة
تسمى  مرحبًا غونغ غونغ في عام 2017 ،
كشفت الأمم المتحدة أنها ساعدت في تحويل
ما لا يقل عن ستة ملايين دولار في
العقود العسكرية إلى بيونغ يانغ. مرحباً ، كيف حالك
يا سيدي عزيزي ، هل ما زالوا
كوريين شماليين في موزمبيق أعراض العم
برنارد في نعم لدينا البعض هنا
يتعاونون في المجال الاجتماعي  والمجالات التقنية
التي تقول إنها لا تتعارض مع
العقوبات التي أعلنتها
الأمم المتحدة ، يقول إنها
تنفذ العقوبات ، رأينا
انتهاكات واضحة رفض مسؤولو وزارة الدفاع
إجراء مقابلات مع شبكة سي إن إن أو
الإجابة على
أسئلتنا ، تنتظر الأمم المتحدة إجابات من
موزمبيق وهي دولة.  المخاطرة بمئات
الملايين من المساعدات الأمريكية التي تساعد كيم
جونغ هون على
إيجاد طرق لتمويل طموحاته النووية
David McKe  nzie سي إن إن مابوتو موزمبيق